the live stream will be able to see each
of us
on screen individually
please announce yourself by name when
speaking
and if you want to refer to anything in
the offices report
can you please first clearly state the
relevant page number
and paragraph number
welcome to rochford district council's
remote licensing and appeals committee
meeting
and welcome to anyone watching this via
live stream
if we can go to a agenda item number one
and take apologies for absence
please i have received um
apologies for counsellor mrs carroll
weston
and councillor mrs joe mcpherson
councillor williams will be a substitute
member
if there's are there any other members
in attendance
non-members
ah this is christian um
counsellor mrs mason yes i
didn't realize you'd moved on to
substitutes and before taking apologies
so apologies for counseling neil hook
way thank you
thank you council mrs mason
okay item number four minutes of the
meeting held on the 3rd of august 2020
and of the subcommittee meetings held on
the 12th and the 26th of october 2020
agreed are the minutes
have been agreed
agreed great agreed okay
do we have any declarations of interest
members
no hands up
okay no declarations of interest
agenda item number six consultation on
the draft statement of the licensing
policy
licensing act 2003 mr steve
greener the council's principal
licensing officer
will present the report at the end of
the report on page 6.2 there is a
recommendation
that the amended statement of licensing
policy
licensing act 2003 be approved
do we have somebody to move a motion on
that
chairman um if if i may i think um it
might be um
it might be a good point to um to invite
you to this degree
to present yeah sorry councillor i'm
sorry steve greener
good morning thank you very much and
this is
in relation to the draft statement of
licensing policy
under the licensing act of 2003.
um every five years we have to review
the policy
and it is coming up for its current
five-year review
with the current one ending on the 6th
of january 2021
previously there was a meeting that i
presented
the draft consultation tea and draft
report
and draft document on the 1st of july
2020
and then what i'm asking today
is for the approval from the members to
place it in front of the full council on
the 15th of december 2020
following the consultation that was
concluded
between the 17th of august to
2020 and the 6th of november 2020
i wrote out to all our existing licensed
premises
our personal license holders and key
partners asking for comment in relation
to
the draft policy we did receive one
response
from a gentleman that just advised me of
some minor typing errors
and numbering areas of bullet points
which have now been amended and the
revised document is back attached
as it's already been requested it's the
recommendation is that
the committee recommends to the full
council for the the policy to be
presented to full council
um on the 15th of december 2020
and that's the end of the report
muted council gooding
do we have somebody that is going to
move the motion
or any questions jeff
um with your commission i've raised my
hand that's to move the motion
to propose do you have any questions
before i
move on
i can't see any hands up so uh
councillor
this mr wilkins uh has moved the
merchant
do you have a second uh oh sorry spiel
there's one of the shorts councillors
sure
the second that thank you
as discussed with the voting um
[Music]
would anyone like a recorded vote to be
taken
if so could you raise your hand icon
please
no hands raised
[Music]
no okay so if we could go straight into
a
um recorded vote then
sorry a vote sorry
sorry check are we are you gonna say
we're voting for
they're not against and then abstains
abstentions
yes we are this is the four this is four
um
you're muted sonia
for the sake of clarity um if if members
could first
um click on their raise hand icon if
they wish to then
vote for the recommendation please
i can't get my hand to raise at the
moment
yeah i've done it
okay sonia i can't see all the raised
icons so
i'll with you on that
chairman um everyone has uh
has has raised their hand voting in
favor it's unanimous
thank you sonia um
do we have any against no
no okay so
that's good the motion is carried
um this will conclude the meeting today
and i would like to thank everyone for
attending the meeting and i now declare
the meeting is
closed at 10 11
thank you very much thank you very much